my new worst [ __ ] pet peeve on
youtube is seeing videos
i've mentioned this to you guys in
private but there's this new like thing
on youtube where like things that
shouldn't be a qualification that are a
qualification
like react to something i've noticed
these things will not stop leaving my
recommended where it's like a japanese
person reacts to every chris abroad
video and i'm like yeah
i don't care that is not impressive that
a japanese person
the reason why i saw that would not
leave my recommended is
a japanese person reacts to uh bill
woods's history of japan
i was like i don't you want like this
should not be a qualification i get it
like there's like like
what was the other ones like doctor
reacts
some because that's that's like an
actual qualification that's just born in
it's not like you were born in like
matchy peach you talking about the ruins
or some [ __ ] that's tiny like
my favorite ones as well was like the
music related ones so it's like i
remember i saw one which was like uh
jazz drama reacts to uh tool live
concert i'm like
but tall is a metal man it's like you
don't know anything about metal
like it's like you play in the it's like
oh yeah the other one is like a church
drummer reacts to whatever and i'm like
you play at your local church
it's not like you're not even a
professional you're just playing your
local church can someone please make a
youtube channel out there like high
school student reacts to high school
like can we because i just want this to
go full meme now like because
it's getting ridiculous like i saw like
there was like a mathematician one
and in the video it was like
mathematician reacts to and i click on
the video
and it's a guy and it's uh just a
college student
what i actually wanted to make a parody
of like that video series which is like
professional degenerate reacts to hentai
i should totally do that i gotta make it
now now you're gonna make that before it
gets saved
yeah this is some people saw the lawyer
things obviously like hey
i'm a specialized japanese person i can
react to
i just don't know no no like not bashing
on any chance to do it i just think it's
really like weird and like not weird
what like unnecessary it's it's it's
kind of like okay there's there's this
trend that makes sense right you have a
professional qualified person who you
know is
has been doing this job like a lawyer or
a doctor
and can actually provide insight yeah
and then
as as with everything as with every
youtube trend it kind of people like try
to
bend it as much as possible to be like
yeah i'm i'm kind of like
i have a qualification in x kind of you
know
you know you know when you're like in in
that job interview and you like try to
buff up
your [ __ ] cv which is with as much
[ __ ] as you can possibly
imagine that's kind of what it feels
like you know so have you ever had any
past jobs well i i used to have to take
out the trash every week at my parents
place
i was kind of like an obligation like i
remember
i remember like back in the abridged
scene where people were just like yeah
i'm i'm
i do i just i do sound design you know
you know
and i'm like [ __ ] you just i
know what the [ __ ] you do you
don't blue
is there any smaller youtubers watching
here's an idea for you like react to
anything but just call yourself
aspiring entrepreneur reacts to
you'll get clicks like that that's free
real estate it's for you okay but to be
fair though the only like
we mentioned this earlier but like the
doctor reacts to uh cells at work
that one's good that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
great no like when when this trend
started i was like i was all for this
yeah
like that i don't often watch reaction
videos but i watched all of those
because
just the dude was a charismatic as [ __ ]
i forgot the name it was like
yeah right yeah
i've seen it i've seen it i think i
think my favorite one is that guy who
breaks down
accents
i mean i was like oh man this is fun i
can explain that not gonna lie when i
saw that on my subject i was like [ __ ]
that's a good idea
yeah yeah i wish i did that yeah i mean
i thought why not man i've been i was
i was actually gonna do something
similar i was gonna do uh i was gonna
name myself japanese expert
and i was gonna and i was gonna react to
uh like
foreigners in films doing japanese
accents or
speaking in japanese right yeah yeah i
might still do that but like
are you a qualified japanese you weren't
you weren't born and raised here joey i
mean
i don't know i have a certificate how
many years experience do you have being
japanese
right only uh 26 years
the amount of videos i have seen that
his japanese person react to filthy
frank is like way too many oh yeah yeah
there's so many it's like this should
not be necessary like
it's just a japanese it's like also it's
like who cares
and also you probably won't get like a
really authentic because most of the
time the japanese people are doing it
doing it in english
yeah they're like you know i mean i'm
not gonna lie but the foreigners that
i've spoken to other japanese people
i've spoken to
that studied abroad are very different
to the the japanese people who oh yeah
very japanese i love about half the
videos as well it's like japanese reacts
to filthy frank and it's just
an american japanese guy right it's like
you're not you're an american dude like
you're not even japanese